Venom is about to become one of the most
powerful beings in existence and this
story is nuts check this out so what
this does is this initially opens up
with Eddie Rock basically Landing in a
place that's beyond seemingly everything
in existence now one of the things that
I do want to point out here is that
Marvel did have a garbage crossover
called Dark web that basically dealt
with the Symbiote really more than like
Eddie Brock Eddie Brock himself and the
Symbiote were basically separated this
is where Eddie Brock went to so what he
ends up doing is kind of waking up and
what is this sort of just ethereal Giant
pool like place and this disembodied
voice kind of keeps talking to him right
just sort of offering this explanation
and what it does is it just kind of
manifests in the form of a physical hand
and what it does is it tells Eddie you
are in the unbion right the antithesis
of Omega the heart of the hive the true
home of the king in black but this is
not a throne room Eddie this is an
engine room it's where we do our work
now this is particularly important right
because what this does is it puts
forward this idea that there does
doesn't seem to be that much
differentiation between the king and
black and the white Phoenix of the crown
the white hot room the reason why I say
that is because before Grant Morrison's
X-Men run a new X-Men all we really had
was just the Phoenix force and it was
just really really powerful but what he
did is he introduced in a story called
here comes tomorrow the white hot room
right the white Phoenix of the crown now
technically the white hot room goes all
the way back to Chris claremont's run
but the idea is that the Phoenix exists
beyond all space and time in this place
where quote unquote works from and that
seems to be a lot of the similarity that
goes on here literally the hand says so
tell me the work that needs doing tell
me what road LED you here ask me your
question and the first thing Eddie Brock
does is he asks about Dylan right he
asked about his son who's the current
host of the Venom symbiote and of course
he gets this small little Glimpse where
he basically sees his son Dylan just
beating the crap out of the gold Goblin
right Norman Osborne which is kind of
cool but it's just a momentary Glimpse
and that's all you really get and so it
tells Eddie you have four more questions
to ask ask me your questions and Eddie
asks about Meridius right he's why I'm
here what do I need need to stop him now
for those of you guys who were catching
up with the Venom stories one of the
things we learned is that after Eddie
Brock became the king in black and
seemingly quote unquote died that what
he did is he woke up in this place that
was completely and totally housed all
the Symbiotes in existence that just
kind of in turn into this kind of
futuristic or I guess almost afterlife
type landscape the whole place was ran
by Meridius and there were these
differing versions of the Venom symbiote
that existed there what we found out in
that story or at least over the course
of that run is that Meridius is almost
Eddie's final form and the other
versions of the Venom symbiote are all
the different stages that Eddie Brock
will go through along the road to being
the king and black so for example the
all red symbiote called Bedlam that's
the form that Eddie Brock takes when his
anger gets the better of him right so on
and so forth but one of the things he
had learned in his time in both fighting
and learning about Meridius is there was
another symbiote Beyond Meridius himself
that if Meridius is a sixth form there
was a seventh form symbiote out there
this is what he was talking about this
is what he was speculating about and so
what the hand says it just says don't
waste this you've known that answer all
along and the response of Eddie is I
need my other right I need both my son
and I need Venom and the response to the
hand is of course you do the question is
how far will you go to reach them and
that's when Eddie kind of gives the
response you would expect from a father
I would go to the ends of the Earth I
would do whatever it is that I have to
do and so that's when the hand asks him
why do you remember the garden so
vividly Eddie right that was the place
where all the different symbiotes and
Meridius were at and the response of
Eddie is it was a graveyard right the
corpse of every other symbiote in
existence that ever lived shaped into a
soulless plastic shell and the question
of the hand asks is is that all it is to
you the scene of a crime and the
response of Eddie is the scene of my
crime right because again he eventually
becomes Meridius and Meridius was the
one who made all that right Meridius
stripped all those symbiotes in
existence of their own minds he
literally broke and shattered their
minds and turned them into what were
basically soulless husks and then in
turn reformed them to create the garden
right that massive place where all the
different symbiotes reside and just kind
of to make out this giant landscape and
so Eddie says I want a question that I
don't know the answer to so here it is
what is the purpose of a power like this
what does it achieve who does it serve
what is the king in Black for now this
is the question that Marvel comic fans
have been asking since the beginnings of
it all right since the very beginning of
everything ever since the start of
Donnie Kate's run the introduction of
null the Symbiote God all that kind of
stuff was Noel just a guy who was there
and he was just an explanation for the
origin of the Symbiotes and like that
was it or is there something more what
Al Ewing does here really I think it's
more RAM V than Al Ewing but like what
he does here what they do is they
basically offer this huge explanation
and what the hand says is that there are
two dominant philosophies when it comes
to Magic there's light magicians who
work from closed off sanctums and lofty
Towers affecting the world from a place
outside and above it an approach that
demands a certain self-denial of the
kind that sometimes builds Heroes but
not always and then the hand goes as far
as to say there are dark magicians who
work from the streets and gutters
changing the world from its broken heart
a path that can create a taste for
worldly power and thus build villains
but not always now the reason why the
hand keeps saying this not always is
because just because a being is
operating with an insane level of power
from the outside and is what we would
call a person that practices white magic
does not mean they are inherently going
to become a superhero that when it comes
to just these insane levels of power
there isn't really a good guy or a bad
guy there are people who achieve insane
levels of power from from virtue of
being what we would call good magic and
they become villains and there are
people who have black magic and they
become Heroes right there's no absolute
truth here and it even says that there
is no inherent moral superiority in
either approach he says because both are
reflections of entities far above and
Far Below far beyond you have come via
limbo the Earth plane's dark opposite to
the black engine where the work is done
but there is another engine tended to by
other Cosmic entities operating on
Cosmic scales from their Cosmic sanctum
believing they can control everything
from outside everything these we call
the ivory Kings the Lords of wild space
the beyonders this is huge dude okay
here's the thing so what this does is it
basically says that the king in black is
the opposite of the beyonders and this
is enormous it's nuts right so here's
the reason why this is so important
reason why this is so important so what
this does is it puts out this idea that
with the beyonders themselves right
getting into this physical love to be
honest getting into this history right
the beyonders were originally just like
some eating Matic race and initially
there was only ever one right Secret
Wars 1984 there's like a crack in space
with light shining through and it says I
am from Beyond basically fight to the
death and whoever wins I'll make your
wildest dreams come true and so that was
all we really had even when you got into
Secret Wars 2 it was still just the
beyonder the reason why that's so
important though is because once you get
into Jonathan Hickman's oh my God
Jonathan Hickman's Avengers and New
Avengers God is the greatest comic book
story ever told but what we got we're
like the beyonders as a race and that
the original Bianna from Secret Wars was
basically a child over the years the
beyonders have been adjusted changed
modified and actually been evolved into
higher states with a more grandiose
purpose but the thing is that the king
in Black are the opposite of that now in
order to be the opposite you kind of
have to be equal to it right equal but
opposite so the idea here is that Eddie
Brock as a king in block with this
person being his final form he says this
the kings in Black are their opposite
numbers Ivory Kings do their work
outside the world Onyx Kings work from
within it and thus you are bound by the
world working not through the clean
precise energies of concordance but
through organic matter wet messy goo
working with the universe in symbiosis
but the work is the same you have to
maintain Eddie Brock you nobody else
keep the Train on the rails keep the
plane in the air keep the whole show
running or give up and embrace the
eternal end and the statement Eddie
Brock makes is null and the response to
the hand is yes exactly like no and the
response of Eddie is to deny it right to
say like this is not right this is not
fair this is not what I asked for and
the response of the hand is null said
the same thing and the response of
idiots it's insane it should be somebody
who can handle it I'm not the right guy
the hand says null said the same and the
response of Eddie is you don't
understand I don't want this job this
work the cosmos should have given it to
somebody who did want it who could do it
why me why does it have to be me Noel
said the same thing so here's the cool
thing behind all this and this is why
this is so awesome because when Donnie
Cates originally introduced null the
Symbiote God in Marvel Comics he just
appeared like a straight up villain
right that's somewhere along the line
the celestials had basically started
crafting everything in existence the
planet's Stars solar systems galaxies
the whole nine yards and had quote
unquote encroached on the territory of
null who was a god of the Abyss right
nothingness the absence of existence and
a war broke out between null and the
sale Industrials if you want to call it
a war null of course overcame one of the
celestials which is where the celestial
head of nowhere comes from he chopped
that celestial's hat off using his own
sword and then of course the celestials
sealed null away but what this does is
it turns the entire thing on its head
that what seems to happen here is that
every Universe has its own King in black
and much like Galactus and Franklin
Richards merging together at the end of
all things and being reborn as a new
cosmic entity in whatever Universe comes
next that the current King in Black will
be reborn into the next Universe either
in his current form as just a kind of
continuation or is potentially somebody
new and that null the Symbiote God was
the original King in Black before the
current Universe came into existence but
the previous King in Black before null
spilled the truth to him about what it
truly means to be a king in black and
much like Eddie Brock he rejected it
didn't want to have any part of it and
ultimately seemed to walk away from it
and that's where the conflict between
the celestials and null came from
because what ends up happening is the
hand says the beyonders got the easy job
Kings and pristine white gloves keeping
their hands clean our hands get dirty
get bloody our hearts get torn and
broken being a king in Black hurts Eddie
and in a time before time a space before
space null could not handle that when
the celestials found him they were not
coming into his void to attack him they
were coming to recruit him they were
coming to give him a job no rejected it
and waged war against the celestials
instead it changes everything we know
about null the Symbiote God why he did
what he did he wasn't really a villain
if anything he was more of a victim he
was a guy who ultimately signed on for a
level of power that he didn't know he
what he was getting into right and he
rejected it and that all hell broke
loose with regards to him and the
celestials and seemingly everything in
existence now the response of Eddie here
is this should have gone to Spider-Man
instead Spider-Man would have been able
to handle this and the response to the
hand is Spider-Man was born for this
role but life happened and he's not here
and you are you bought the ticket Eddie
someone body has to take the rod now
here's why that's so important Peter
Parker was the one who originally gained
the Venom symbiote right in secret Wars
1984. Peter Parker came across the
Symbian not fully understanding what it
was he bonded to it and it wasn't until
he got back to Earth and he was like
basically traveling around the city in
his sleep with a symbiote controlling
his body attacking villains being more
of a vigilante than anything else and so
Peter Parker goes to a bell tower he
casts the Symbiote off the Symbiote out
of anger bonds itself to Eddie Brock and
the rest is history so ultimately this
was supposed to be Spider-Man it's how
things were supposed to play out but it
didn't Peter Parker casts off the
Symbiote before he could even learn what
it meant to be bonded to the Symbiote in
the first place of basically becoming
the opposite and equal in power of the
beyonders and ultimately this Rule now
went to Eddie Brock instead and so Eddie
kind of makes us off-handed statement
where he says Meridius didn't want to
take the ride either did he and when the
hand asks him is that your fourth
question the response of Eddie is not
quite when I say Meridius didn't want
this it's that he didn't want to be you
so who are you give me the long answer
and the Hand kind of pauses for a second
and says smart thinking you already know
the short answer I'm you I'm Eddie Brock
but I'm so much more than that call me
the eventuality and he says null is a
straight line he tries to destroy
everything he fails and that's his
timeline over with the timeline of the
true king and block for this reality is
more complicated Eddie Brock takes the
throne meaning Eddie Brock gets the
Symbiote for the first time and then
everything transpires he defeats null
and then he becomes a king in black and
he says and unlike his opposites in the
Beyond he's non-linear unstuck in time
your path has already forked once during
that moment of decision in limbo it will
Fork again and again and he says you
will travel back and forth hither and
yawn restless rootless and a forgotten
pass into possible Futures you'll lose
this power you'll regain it you'll lose
it again that will happen and it won't
already did and already didn't from here
I can see the whole map the whole maze
so many choices you make From Here Eddie
so many paths and every single one of
them leads to me when after far longer
than your Cosmos will last your work in
the world is finally done you come here
to supervise so what this basically
means here are those of you guys who are
familiar with the Multiverse every
universe is a possibility based off the
main Marvel Universe right so let's wind
the clock back to win Eddie Brock first
got the Symbiote right so the main
Marvel Universe timeline is Peter Parker
casts off the Symbiote and one of
Spider-Man number 45 Eddie Brock gets
the Symbiote instead right what the hand
is saying is a saying no matter what
happens you will always end up here so
say for example Spider-Man cast off the
Venom symbiote and it just happened to
be that like Iron Man was there the
Symbiote would Bond itself to Iron Man
and then things would transpire or maybe
the Symbiote leaves Iron Man and it
bonds itself to Captain America things
would transpire and then it would
ultimately bond to Eddie Brock this was
always going to happen no matter how
things transpire for Eddie he will
always end up there and that's why it
says that your timeline has 4 worked and
will continue to Fork there are an
infinite number of possibilities for you
Eddie Brock you could have died to null
but somehow you would have returned and
somehow you would have become the king
in black no matter what happens you
always end up here and when Eddie asks
what do you mean by supervise the
response to the hand is a little
prodding here and there like I'm doing
now keeping a whole Venom verse of Kings
in black on the rails so we don't get
another null or maybe we do when this
Cosmos ends and the new one begins I
will be there renewed by The Cosmic void
awaiting to greet a new King in Black
maybe I'll be the next king in Black the
bad guy the fire The Temper is my
replacement or maybe I'll just be a guy
on Earth and I'll buy a Maserati either
way I plan to enjoy my retirement and so
when Eddie says meanwhile I'm the sap
stuck on your factory floor the response
to the hand is we're all stuck Eddie all
the iterations of me everybody's stuck
in their lives that's what broke
Meridius what caused all of this and the
response of Eddie is what causes you you
right this is what causes you and so
this was one of the biggest moments here
because what Eddie says is he says
you're what I become one way or another
or a hundred other ways besides I get
that what I don't get is what I am now
Eddie Brock's body is a charred skeleton
in a morgue someplace so what's standing
here instead and the response to the
hand is a loner you needed something to
wear and the response of Eddie is no no
riddles no glimpses I'm asking my last
question my body's gone this thing I'm
wearing has to be a goo construct of
some kind but it's real my scalp itches
my eye stings my back's aching this
whole time how can that be if I do not
have a physical body then how can I feel
like this physical body is real what am
I and the response of the hand is more
than you think you've got a power in you
that can save your son save your other
maybe save everything that is if you
just let yourself see it your son is
half human half symbiote he got there
the easy way he was born but you had to
take the back road you died and your
mind jumped seeking out a body that
belonged to you that fell under your
jurisdiction so with that knowledge you
jumped to the Garden a place made of
dead symbiote flesh so is that the only
dead flesh in all of time and space
that's yours let me spill it out for you
Eddie you have absolute power over any
flesh you command and while symbiote
bodies are shared among all the kings
and black the human body of Eddie Brock
at the time that you inhabited is yours
alone that in effect what it's saying is
that yes you have control over all
symbiotes in existence but it's not as
simple as you command them and tell them
what to do you are a fully functional
symbiote you are a human being in
symbiote form or a symbiote in human
being form you can bring yourself back
from the dead at any point in time you
can take on any form you want to you're
a living breathing symbiote Eddie you
are nigh indestructible channeling a
love level of power that you couldn't
possibly begin to comprehend while Eddie
is the opposite in his role of the
beyonders he seemingly equal in power he
can manipulate and control all things in
existence he can literally move anywhere
he wants throughout the time stream
Eddie Brock is by all standards of
measurement Godly powerful right now
this is particularly important here
because what Eddie Brock does is in
realizing this takes on his actual full
form which is basically the Venom symbol
across his chest which looks dope but
I'm excited about this because as you
guys know right now Avengers Beyond is a
thing and Marvel's building up to like
this whole new Godly Pantheon being
written by Jonathan Hickman Eddie Brock
seems to basically become a new cosmic
entity but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this to an end thank
you all for watching and I will catch
you all later
peace